President Trump and Democrats set to
collide on two key issues the border
wall and Obamacare first with the
potential partial government shutdown
looming just four days away the White
House and Democrats continue to clash
over border spending Senator Chuck
Schumer claiming there's no way
lawmakers will greenlight funding for
the wall president Trump should
understand there are not the votes for
the wall in the house or the Senate he
is not going to get the wall in any form
even the house which is a majority
Republican they don't have the votes for
his five billion dollar wall plan but
White House adviser Stephen Miller says
the president is not going to blink on
the issue we're gonna do whatever is
necessary to build the border wall to
stop this ongoing crisis of illegal
immigration the Democrat Party is a
simple choice they can either choose to
fight for America's working class or to
promote illegal immigration you can't do
both
also president Trump ready to replace
Obamacare after a federal judge rules it
to be unconstitutional Democrats already
lining up to challenge the decision
President Obama and other top Democrats
are vowing to fight while others are
using it to push for universal health
care which we will probably hear a lot
about can we just call up the
president's tweet about the border if we
could and I will provide that to the
viewer where he said anytime you hear a
Democrat saying that you can't have a
good border security without a wall
write them off it's just another
politician following the party line time
to save us billions of dollars a year
and have at the same time for our
greater safety and control Greg that was
the border was spelled correctly in that
tweet look it's it's a I I can solve
this problem combined the border wall
and Obamacare if you build the wall you
get free health care huh that's why I'm
2024 everybody would I find interstate
if nobody no one likes that I did I
don't know Mexico built a wall it gets
free health care here's what I think I
wish the irony of all this I'm punch
drunk for the Democrats governor
government is the answer for everything
right it's it's the answer right now for
health care you
Obamacare is government it's for
everything except the wall that is where
the government happily abdicates the
responsibility and says we want nothing
to do with it
which makes no sense at all so if you
say the government should take over a
health care why don't you do the wall as
well I don't understand it
Jesse a poll of in the USA Today poll I
thought this was pretty interesting yes
it's true a majority of Americans oppose
a government shutdown but it was only
54% 54 to 29% the country has a stomach
for a shutdown and so what you can't go
to the National Park who cares to stay
open yeah better even better so probably
Rockets to 75% in the spirit of Greg's
bipartisanship I think Trump hit the
nail on the head when he said put solar
panels on the wall yes to get the
Democrats to vote for it the president
said he wants the ownership of the shut
down I don't think he necessarily needs
to take that because I believe the
Democrats in the Senate would own the
shutdown if you think about the fact
that this president was elected by the
American people to provide border
security he has a mandate to build the
wall currently he still has control over
the House and the Senate
if they send up to the Senate wall
funding at five billion in a budget then
it's the Senate Democrats who are the
intransigent ones and should own the
shutdown I don't understand how this is
being framed as Donald Trump's fault
look at the spending he only wants three
and a half billion more in a four
trillion dollar budget I ran the numbers
damn right that comes out to a point
zero seven five percent it's not a lot
less than 1/10 of a percent that's what
they're fighting over so you don't
understand it's not about security it's
not about principles it's just about
politics they don't want to hand the
president a victory and the other reason
is they know all walls work and they
don't want to leave a lasting reminder
what Trump was president everybody to
see for generally the Trump wall exactly
yeah so well I just statue they can't
tear down yeah takes a while you want to
talk about the shutdown possibilities or
Obamacare or do you want to do something
very innovative like Greg did and
combine the two I invite her and Shelley
I was I was overwhelmed
peanut butter and jelly but on the other
hand I think you guys are just making a
spoof out of this cuz it's just you know
it's kind of crazy you know I mean you
said Oh what what's different I'm going
to tell you something what - Merced is
right he's has the house and he has the
Senate but he doesn't have the votes I
don't believe that oh but why doesn't
the house vote Jesse they will oh no
they're waiting for crunch time yeah
well let me tell you crunch time is
gonna come half of them won't even be
there because a lot of the people who
were defeated are just staying home so
this is not a good situation for the
president and Jesse while you say hey
you think the Democrats should take
responsibility let's go to the videotape
I know he did it
coño who's the Senate Majority Leader
has already said he doesn't want this
he's trying to figure it out because he
doesn't want to buck the president he
wants to stay loyal to the president
he's on record as saying he wants yes
you know what he's on record saying he
wants Trump support when he's up for
reelection next year and he'll get it
yeah fine but he can't but nobody in the
Senate takes this seriously in fact what
you heard from John Cornyn when he saw
want to take responsibility for the
coming shutdown and say oh my god what
did he do I can't believe it from Truman
there was a lot of political pressure
before the midterm with Republicans
saying don't say you're gonna shut down
the government before the midterms but
now that the midterms are over the
Republicans kept the Senate they lost a
lot of seats in the house at like 39 40
seats in the house so now that political
pressure isn't there so this shutdown
could last a while that's true and I
think he's taking credit for the
shutdown because he wants to prove that
he has some guts Republicans are always
such a bunch of scaredy cats Democrats
run with this language about a
government shutdown they scare the heck
out of everybody they don't tell you
that your Social Security checks are
still gonna go out and Medicare and
Medicaid are gonna function properly the
military's gonna stay on the post office
is going to stay open instead they make
you feel like it's Armageddon and he's
sitting there Trump and he's saying you
know what if I have to shut down do this
partial shutdown of the government like
you said maybe some of the parts won't
stay open or maybe they will I'm gonna
do it because this issue of border
security is that important this is a
humanitarian crisis going on on the
border if no other Republican has the
guts to say I'm either gonna get this
done or I'm gonna have to do a partial
shutdown to show that I'm not kidding
he's willing to do it and I commend him
for that I do think though that it shows
these two issues that we're talking
about we're talking about Obamacare
we're talking about the border I think
it shows such a vast difference in terms
of how the left in the right view of the
world that when Trump was optimistic
about them coming together and saying Oh
on these issues you know I have a lot of
Democratic friends I think we can sit at
the table I don't know I mean when
you're talking about free-market
healthcare and on the other side you've
got something as drastic as Medicare for
all
that is government-run health care
versus individuals running their own
health care making their own decisions
those things are worlds and worlds are
challenged I don't know how you meet
what you're talking about is we've
talked about this before we are living
in the prison of two ideas both of these
up but you're talking healthcare and the
wall are in the prison of two ideas the
Republicans they like order and
Democrats we like compassion so they
think that these can't be combined so
you're in a prison of two ideas then you
look at Obamacare Republicans say free
market solution the Democrats say
compassion government-centered solutions
again
no one believes that they can come
together so you're in a prison of two
ideas when in fact there is a solution
in the middle for each one of these
things it's gonna in for but I think all
of it it's going to be solved by
technology well somebody's going to
figure it I've always said the wall is
compassionate in it you'll be passionate
you said scan worker and it's
compassionate for all these people
coming up from Central America they
don't have to res like a brick it's like
a brick house up there that's what we
need sprays that can spray the wall I
don't disclose the product okay find a
gate slide right off wait a second
Republicans have been in charge Greg and
they haven't been able to repeal and
replace Obamacare right and Obamacare is
now this is unbelievable
it's like something that's just been
hanging around to the point where people
think it's still there let it let it
stay but I do think that technology
you're already seeing doctors doing
basically FaceTime and Skype visits this
this technology is going to solve this
problem if we let it you know
soon as the key you you're right because
they twist that word the left twist that
word where the compassion it's not
compassionate to have a humanitarian
crisis at the border it's not
compassionate to have health care costs
rising for people that they can't afford
and having them now have plans having a
program that was shoved down their
throat with lies where they can't keep
their plan they can't keep their doctor
government-run health care is not
compassionate anywhere that's why people
flee those countries and come to nice in
other words people who are suffering
from the opioid crisis and can't afford
to get care or attention for medically
oh way if you by the way you said
Republicans like order yeah what's going
on if you do away with Obamacare right
now just chaos in terms of petition
nothing is changing so if you have
Obamacare and you don't have to worry at
this point everything's still maybe you
can find the W like your Obamacare yeah